what's going on everybody and welcome to
a new tutorial series in the series what
we're gonna be covering is Google cloud
we're not gonna be able to go through
everything that Google plot has to offer
but at least some of the things so to
get there it's cloud Google com if this
is your first account you should get
$300 in credit to play around with so
hopefully this doesn't cost you a thing
now when you come here you can go to
products and see basically all the
things that are available the first
thing we're going to cover and cover in
this tutorial is the compute engine
which is just your typical virtual
machine but they also have all kinds of
stuff like storage and obviously more
computation some networking stuff big
data like bigquery machine learning
tasks they just simple cloud machine
learning they've got I'm not quite
positive with cloud obviously it's
something for job discovery and search
but I'm not quite sure how that works
they've got a natural language API which
I plan to cover speech API which I would
like to cover not positive I'm going to
do it especially since it's in beta
right now the translation API which I
would like to cover and the vision API
which I would definitely like to cover
will maybe do video intelligence if it
exits private beta anyway
the first thing we're going to do is the
the compute engine so one once you like
sign in and create account generally to
get where you want to be usually going
to go to console so I'll head there and
I already have some stuff set up here
you can see I've spent a whopping 8 pins
crazy if you have just created an
account chances are you've already got a
project kind of created for you but if
you have had an account for a long time
or whatever you can come up here and hit
this drop down and either create a new
project or kind of work off an existing
project so I've got tutorials here I'm
good to go so the first thing that I'm
going to do is get to the just we're
just going to do a simple virtual
machine so this is something that would
compete with digitalocean or AWS ec2
something like that although I don't
know 100% if it's a lot I don't think
it's actually elastic but anyway I'm not
going to get into semantics right now
but anyways kind of compete with any
sort of virtual
private server so to get there come to
the little hamburger saying click on
that come on down to compute engine and
what we're going to do is go ahead and
hit create here
once we're created you call whatever you
want I'm going to call it students and
then you can pick various zones just I'm
going to choose you a central release I
thought it was going to be you a central
D maybe it's us East one D let me try
that one and then what I'm going to do
is click on customize here for the
machine type you can see it kind of
defaults to this one CPU in 375
gigabytes of memory but I'm gonna go
ahead and hit customize here choose GPUs
yeah okay cool so under various zones
there's only three there's one in Asia
US and I think somewhere in Europe yeah
somewhere in Europe um you can do GPUs
so I'm just going to point that out what
a single GPU is going to cost you about
seventy-three cents an hour although
this is probably unrealistic you would
have a much larger drive to so let's let
me just make it something realistic
let's do a hundred gigabytes of an SSD
let's just say that's what we wanted to
go it's okay yes still 75 cents an hour
mostly what you're paying for is that K
80 now compared to both Amazon and Asher
I'm pretty sure that it's actually
cheaper than both of those providers it
can be kind of hard because a lot of
times those provide like I remember when
as your first Asher was like the first
to announce GPUs they were kind of
treating them because if you don't know
a K eighties actually kind of two GPUs
glued together so they were kind of
doing their pricing in terms of half GPU
so anyway it got kind of convoluted but
anyways this is not a GPU server
tutorial so actually I'm going to go to
zero none GPUs and then I'm going to
choose two virtual CPUs let's say and
let's go with smaller disk that's for
sure
let's go with like 60 so with a 60 this
is basically the same size
server from like digital ocean for
example costs actually bought 40 bucks a
month so this is actually significantly
more expensive than digital ocean if
these are the exact sizes you want but
if you want to be able to actually
customize your server and you actually
have a little bit of wiggle room in here
to have maybe you want 12 gigs of memory
but you're still only want 2 CPUs or
maybe you want one shared CPU although
this one doesn't give you much choice we
are actually going to go with the shared
CPU but anyway you have a lot more
wiggle room with with how much you know
what exactly you want to actually
customize but we're going to go with a
shared CPU here for memory will go with
1.7 egg wow that really the huge
difference let's see what was this one
14:08 let's try a different area too
maybe that was just really expensive
maybe Houston's these are all basically
the same the other thing I want to point
out is like if you pick if you pick
different zones the pricing will be
different usually why is the point there
we go at least that one changed for
summer you pretty much all the US ones
seem to be the same price a lot of times
the u.s. part there we go that one's
cheaper 315 versus three oh is it
cheaper it's not I guess I'm fooling
with myself anyway um yeah cool so let's
go with one shared GPU or CPU rather and
then maybe it's the disk size will
change the distance here in a second so
make sure you've got one shared CPU
that'll be cheap we'll go with one seven
gigabytes actually we'll stick with the
six that's fine we're going to be doing
any huge computing here and now let's go
ahead and change the boot disk we're
going to choose Ubuntu 1604 and for the
size let's do
I don't know I don't think we really
recommend much for this tutorial so
what's that sixes 643 a month cool both
will do it hopefully that'll be enough
identity in access basically I've
already got these two let me do
[Music]
let's do no service again and then let's
come down here and I'm going to go to
SSH key so the service accounts will
kind of talk about that's for like the
API access so I've already done that
that's why I had something to choose
from but I'm going to choose no for now
just because I don't want I want us to
all be on the same page so coming on
down to SSH keys this is how we're
actually going to connect to our server
so so if you're on Windows you're going
to want to come to putty org download
putty
there's your any putty and then also
puttygen which should come with your
installation of pipe if you're on Mac or
Linux you can if you just like Google
connecting to a server or probably if
you just come here and you type like
connecting connect like okay I'll put
this link in the description then I
guess so if I forget to someone can poke
at me but you can come down here and for
generating SSH keys and pairing it and
all that these are all the instructions
that you would need I'm going to do the
Windows version because that's the
machine I'm on right now so anyway so
SSH key so let's say you are on Windows
like me make sure you download putty go
ahead and pause it if you don't have
putty already and if you do open up
pledge in wow Mike I'm doing my best to
open it up there we go buddy - okay so
when you got put again go ahead and
click generate wiggle your mouse up here
generates random data you've got your
key you can change the key comment to be
your user name on your server so I'm
going to choose HS kinsley and that's
basically all you have to do that should
modify this right so down here is where
your comment would be so go ahead and
highlight and copy all of this key and
then paste it into this box here make
sure you can see it and then you should
see this updates over here as the user
which is now HS kimbley coming back over
here make sure you save the public key
and I'm just going to save it as public
and then save a private team if you want
you can add a password that's probably
to yell at me
yes it did are you sure you want to save
this key without yes I'm positive and
I'm going to say this is private under
normal circumstances you probably would
want to set a password to it but this
isn't a server then I'm going to care
that much about so I'm not going to do
it once you've done that close out and
you're done with this step and go ahead
and hit create and this should be a
pretty quick process you should have
your server within probably 60 seconds
especially as a small one like this I'm
tempted to pause while we wait but
hopefully it'll come up pretty quickly I
guess while we wait I'm going to open up
putty and if you're like me and you do
need to do the the keys on Windows go
ahead and open putty come to SSH there
it is the server updated so now we have
an IP to connect to go to off kind of
small but bear with me and then browse
for the private key file should open up
right to the same place you saved it but
if not go back and check to that path
and then let's take that private key
that's all you have to do now come back
to the session and what we're going to
do is take this IP the external IP copy
paste that into the host and go ahead
and just hit enter you should get this
just as this is a warning but hey this
key is not already in your registry are
you sure you're like are you meaning to
connect to a new server I am go ahead
and type in whatever that username was
it authenticates with that key that we
just said and boom we are in with our
simple virtual machine here so one thing
that is cool is you can do things like
cigarettes and install a CH top and you
don't have a type of password or
anything
it's a pseudo less or suta list it's a
password list pseudo so to use pseudo
you don't need a password same things
that you wanted to go into route sudo su
boom I'm route so interesting kind of
set there but anyway obviously yes if
you wanted to change your password you
could just do sudo password or you can
do password username and so on if you
want to change a password and have one
but you really don't need one your key
is going to do all your password needs
for you anyways okay so
that's it for the just the introduction
to Google cloud but we're going to be
getting into some of the api's in the
next tutorial if you have any questions
comments concerns whatever leading up to
this point feel free to leave them below
keep the virtual machine we're actually
going to continue following along the
tutorials in this virtual machine so
don't destroy it or whatever and that's
it so I'll see you in the next video